[موسيقى]
السبب الرئيسي هو قد يكون انخفاض مستوى
السكر في الدم
سبب اخر يكون الجفاف بسبب عدم تناول كميات
كافيه من الماء خلال فترات الافطار ما بين
فتره الافطار الى فتره السحور سبب اخر قد
يكون
نقص في نسبه الكافيين لان الاشخاص معروف
عنهم يشربون القهوه بصوره كبيره في ايام
رمضان بسبب نقص ماده الكافيين قد يكون
عرضه للاصابه بصداع اكثر من غيرهم
الاشخاص المدخنون يكونون عرض اكثر بسبب
نقص ماده النيكوتين في الدم نسبه
الكيكوتين في الدم تزيد نسبه حدوث الصداع
في ايام رمضان من الاسباب الاخرى اللي هي
عدم انتظام الاكل يعني الشخص العادي في
الايام الافطار ياخذ وجبه افطار وغداء
وعشاء بينما في ايام رمضان قد يكون وجبتين
فقط افطار وسحور وفي كثير من الناس قد
يتناسوا او ينسوا فتره او يهملوا
يعني في وجبه السحور وهي وجبه ضروريه جدا
للحصول الجسم على كميات كافيه من الغذاء
والماء للحفاظ على جسم سليم خلال فتره
الصيام
انصح يعني
لتجنب هذه المشاكل الحصول على كميات كافيه
من الماء خلال فتره الافطار تناول وجبات
سحور صحيه ومتكامله
تجنب شرب القهوه او تقليل شرب القهوه ما
بين ما قبل شهر رمضان مثلا باسبوعين او
ثلاث حتى نخفف هاي الامور حتى التدخين
المدخنين يحاولوا يخففوا التدخين قبل شهر
رمضان النوم بصوره منتظمه حتى خلال شهر
رمضان
[موسيقى]